and i think this is a problem that you
see across the whole the whole landscape
here
um when we talk about how widespread the
problem is
that in so many of these areas a lot of
people affected by it
can't talk about it or are afraid to
talk about it because of the
professional repercussions and another
great example of that
uh the other article you wrote for a
wall street journal about in the
the the situation in women's prisons
where men
are being um are being sent into women's
prisons
and there's certainly a place where
these these women have no voice
um and they they have no real way unless
someone like you comes along they have
no way to get their story out there
so can you talk about that uh a little
bit these these
are men who if i understand correctly
and i guess
it depends depends on the state a little
bit but they don't have to have
surgery or anything right they uh not
that that even would make it okay but
they don't have surgery or anything
right these these are just men who are
being put in women's prisons because
they declare
that they feel like women yeah and they
so i talked to the women of the
chauchila prison which is the highest
security it's
technically called the central
california uh correctional facility
colloquially
known as the chowchilla prison and this
is the highest security women's prison
in the state of california
these women are tough women but they are
terrified because
now a new law allows men biological men
to transfer in all they need to do is
declare
a female identity no surgery or hormones
are required
for them to become eligible for transfer
and the reason and that we have these
laws
in a few states now washington um has
the same policy a woman was raped by one
of the biological men who was placed in
her prison
um i've been in you know um sorry there
there have even been serial rapists
who are declared a female identity and
were put in women's prison in the state
of washington
and the problem is even more serious
than and dire than i
you know that i was able to convey
because
in the future as these laws you know
continue to
exist um right now the men are
transferring
into women's prison from men's prison so
we can track them
but you know in laws like washington
where you can just
change your birth certificate and in
california where you go into the system
now
as a female it will be extremely
difficult for reporters to even be able
to track
who who these men were it will look like
women on women violence when they rape
and assault the female inmates
and part of the problem right is that in
women women's prisons a lot of them
anyway
they don't they don't segregate based on
the severity of crime as strictly as
they do in men's prisons because there
isn't as much violence to begin with
until you start putting the men in there
um so you could have
you know a man convicted of murder in
there with women who what
you know shoplifted or something right
well yeah i mean
one thing that i learned from the women
prisoners which i didn't know and
i was able to corroborate was that a lot
of not only
are a huge number of female prisoners uh
abuse survivors sexual abuse survivors
but very often when they committed
crimes and they committed a lot of these
women committed very serious crimes
they did it at the at the behest of a
scary man they were involved with
so um these are women who are have been
pushed around by men their whole lives
um and um are even though you know
these are very tough women um the men
transferring in the men
male convicts are are quite quite scary
um they're huge often they are extremely
strong
and they can easily overpower them and
these women are terrified
you mentioned uh the one case of a woman
who was raped by a male
prisoner sent in there are you aware of
any other cases because it strikes me
that this
is probably happening a lot just given
what we're doing here the how we're
mixing things together um but it also
strikes me that we
would we would never find out about it
so are you aware of any other
cases uh like that it's it's
i i am not and i'll tell you why it's
very complicated because you hear
even from the women that the men who are
in there can very often
even if there's a sexual relationship
it's hard to tell if it's consensual
and the reason is is the women are
trapped in small cells with them
so the women will in some cases will say
that the
it is consensual um but but a lot of the
you know other prisoners disbelieve that
um
given how much much stronger the men are
and how trapped the women feel
and and remember these these cells women
are the
women's cells are everyone is just
together there aren't
you don't because women are less violent
they're not set up to keep people
separate or to safeguard women
from each other so the men who enter
really have free reign
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends